- You're spearheading
actually something called
the #NotAlone Challenge.
So tell us about that.
- Yeah, so I moved out at 15.
I knew statistically, kids like me
end up repeating the cycle
and I didn't wanna be a statistic.
I grew up in a family where
abuse had been generational
and so, I wanted to see if
happiness was a learnable skill.
So, I learned a lot of skills for myself
that really helped me learn
what I call a new emotional language,
because not everybody
has access to therapy.
In fact, 50% of the people
that need mental health help
don't have access to any tools.
And happiness shouldn't be elite.
It shouldn't be just for the people
that can afford something
or afford a therapist.
So the #NotAlone Challenge
is bringing proven tools
that can scale to everybody
that lives in these mental health deserts.
- I love, that is so important.
And it's also like, not only
that people can't afford it.
I know people like from
where I'm from in the South,
it's still kind of looked down upon
and people get shamed for it,
which is such a crazy thing to me,
for lack of a better word,
because it's one of those things
it's nice to have somebody
outside your circle
that literally is trained in
ways to help you navigate,
give you tools with whatever
you're dealing with.
It's like if you need help with your car,
you go to a mechanic, if you need help,
you know what I'm saying?
It just seems so natural to me,
but it's not only, it's
amazing 'cause the money
but also, I think society
needs to really change
and evolve in the sense of
quit shaming people for it
or looking down upon it.
- Yeah.
- But how could people get involved?
- Oh, if you wanna get involved,
go to NotAlonechallenge.org
and there you'll find a lot of
mental health tools for free.
You'll find a ton of resources
and then you can also find all
of our auction items there.
And we have incredible auction items.
We're raising money to be able
to scale proven behavioral tools
so that everybody has access to them.
(audience clapping)
- That's incredible,
Jewel, that's so cool.
So I hear that there's an auction
and even like tickets,
from sports tickets to
like Billy Eilish tickets.
You're offering something
cool as well, right?
- Yeah, I thought that I would
write a personalized song
so people can bid on a
song that I'll write.
I'll write about your dog
if that's what you want
me to write it about.
I'll write about your mama,
I'll write about your son.
But I thought that'd be fun
so people can bid on that.
- I love, that's such a cool thing.
It's such a personal
thing to do for someone.
It's really cool.